What if the flappers were
writing in fact flat?
How would gravity,
Burke,
would we still have times
change of seasons with the
conditions for life here on
earth exists at all? This is
what if, and here's what the
look like if it was flat,
first of all,
forget about walking to its edge.
Gravity with simply not let you wait.
He drive it even be possible on a flat
earth. The answer is yes, of course.
The force of gravity is what keeps our
plant or any other planet together.
It's what forms a planet
in the first place.
In the case of a pancake shaped earth,
the force of gravity would pull you to
the center and will become stronger as he
tried to walk away from it.
Pulling the top of your body backwards.
It would feel as if you
were climbing a hill.
A Hilda was getting steeper
and steeper and steeper.
By the time you reach the edge down and
behind you would be the same direction.
Sound Weird?
How about water being sucked into the
center of the earth or diagonal trees
growing in the opposite
direction of gravity's pulling
and then there's the sun.
How would a flat earth behave in space?
One flat earth theory is that the
sun revolves around the earth,
not the other way around.
What if the sun orbited the earth
just like the moon does? In that case,
you'd never suffered jet lag because
there'd be no such thing as time zones.
The Sun would light up both the
top and the bottom of the planet.
This would mean constant light,
no day and night cycle.
Also no seasons or solar eclipses.
The Sun itself would
have to be much smaller,
otherwise it would burn
the earth to a crisp.
It would probably fry the planet anyway
as there would be no geomagnetic field
to protect earth from its radiation.
The geomagnetic field is generated in
the solid core of the earth and keeps our
atmosphere from escaping.
Without it,
cosmic rays would bombard our bodies
causing everything from cancer to DNA
damage.
The oceans would escape into space and
so with the air and all our oxygen,
but let's assume that a flat earth had
an alternative to our magnetic field.
This way you'd still be alive to notice
some of the strange flat earth affects
like your shadow.
Say you had a friend just as tall as you,
but they lived a thousand miles
away. On a sunny day, your shadow is,
would be the very same length because
unlike here on a spherical earth,
the sun's rays would hit both of you at
the same angle and if you were to meet
up,
traveling would turn out very different.
Let's take a map introduced by
the flat Earth Society. Yeah,
the one that shows the Arctic
at the center and Antarctica
as an ice wall around
the edges in this world,
it would take you 32 hours to
fly from Australia to Argentina.
Did we mentioned there'd be
no gps satellites wouldn't
be able to orbit a flat
earth leaving humanity with no
navigation and no synchronized time.
This means no a tms,
no credit cards,
no high speed stock market transactions
on the bright side with a good pair of
binoculars. You could see Dubai Burj
Khalifa from any part of the flat world,
but let's be honest,
you don't need to build your own rocket
to see that the earth is not flat.
The evidence is all around us.